daniel radcliffe experienced a different
kind of danger when he first shot
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone 20
years ago
daniel explaining his wild onset scare
to our lauren zema
i'm harry harry potter is there one
scene you would go back and redo if you
could
they let me do the coolest stunt i've
ever been able to do was a
a 40 foot full down a roof
i was absolutely terrified but they were
like you can do this do you want to try
it and i
said yes then got up there and was
absolutely terrified i've realized since
that
that was very special circumstance on
that set and i will never be allowed to
do something like that again
daniel was just 11 years old when he was
cast as the boy who lived he
made eight movies altogether and told us
back then that seeing himself on screen
in the first one
was an emotional experience i cried
because i just
couldn't believe my name was daniel
radcliffe and it was on the credits list
if you watch the movies at all since
they first came out um not since they
first came out i've seen like bits
uh on tv for seconds before i go like oh
or if it's a scene someone else is in
i'll be like oh cool
daniel's latest project is a little more
adult his dark comedy miracle workers is
back for season three
this time it's set in the 1840s on the
oregon trail
daniel's reverend and steve buscemi is
an outlaw in the anthology series that
returns today to tbs
hope you catch that sexy outlaw what was
fun about playing benny the teen is that
i think he
really enjoys being an outlaw what was
it like to don
these period costumes and getting a
covered wagon i love like period clothes
and i also basically just had one
costume for most of this season which is
great
can i get an amen